that unfortunately they just don't want
to print it but I want to thank the
governor serving here very much we
appreciate it we're gonna have some good
fruitful talks about going even to the
next step and I know you're trying to
open up and you're opening up you sort
of more than trying you're opening up
and now you both you both doing an
excellent job and it's an honor very
much these two gentlemen have done a
fantastic job and David you know from
interior and David's very much involved
with the estates and how are they doing
David what do you think antastic I think
so they're doing a good job they really
are they doing a good job we're talking
about as you know space force and a lot
of the states are interested in space
force and we were talking to some of
them and I know that Colorado is very
interested in it and so we'll be talking
to you about that too okay we might
mention that today a little bit during
our meeting so thank you all very much
thank you
administrators and school principals
around the country in terms of their
plans to reopen school and colleges in
the fall oh I think they should open the
schools absolutely I think they should
and it's had very little impact on young
people and I think that if you're an
instructor if you're a teacher professor
and you're over a certain age like let's
say 65 or maybe even if you want to be
conservative 60 perhaps you want to stay
out for a little while longer but I
think you should absolutely open the
schools our country's got to get back
and it's got to get back as soon as
possible and I don't consider our
country coming back if the schools are
closed and it's a very little very
unusual situation has had very little
impact on young people and I would
strongly say they should open it's up to
the governor's it's the governor's
choice but the estate is not open if the
schools are open so again it's a very
little impact on young people and I
think they should open their schools
[Music]
to sanction China would you support it
if it goes to you in the house and it
comes to this well I respect Lindsey
Graham and I'll certainly look at it the
bill to sanction China so I'll certainly
take a look at it I have not seen it yet
well the unmasking is a massive -
massive thing it's I just got a list
it's who can believe a thing like this
and I watched Biden yesterday on Good
Morning America being interviewed by one
of your colleagues George Stephanopoulos
and he said you know not think about
anything
he has no idea he knows nothing about
anything nothing at all and then it gets
released today that he was a big young
massacre
so how do you know nothing if you're one
of the unmasked Asst it's one of the
very big stories and I suspect you'll
have if it's possible even bigger
stories coming out
number of explosions in Afghanistan
look Afghanistan we've been there for
many years we're like a police force
we're not fighting in Afghanistan we're
a police force in Afghanistan and at
some point they're gonna have to be able
to take care of their country they're
gonna have to be able to police their
country but we're not meant to be a
police force we went to be fighters and
we've been there for a long time so I
don't know I'll have to see it I have
not heard that see if we have had in
Kabul we've had some I understand some
pretty big blow ups but again you count
on a government to be able to police
themselves and they're having a hard
time I suspect but again we are the
greatest fighting force in the world
we're not a police force that's going to
stay around and police the streets and
check out the red lights and traffic
it's not what we're supposed to be doing
been there a long time you know our
forces down quite a bit as you know when
we do and a lot of people have come back
brought them back but the government has
to be able at some point to do something
for themselves I know that you said we
could wait and see on stimulus that you
well I'm a believer and they could have
reached only of other countries that are
competitors with Germany they're an ally
they're friends of ours but there's
still competitors or trade and other
things so Germany Japan others have
negative rates and I think if they do
we're the most prime of the world you
know where it's based many countries
based on the dollar the dollar is by far
the strongest most powerful currency in
the world we've made it more powerful
we've made it stronger and certainly if
they're gonna have the advantage of
negative rates we should too I feel
strongly we should have negative rates
negative rates is basically where they
pay you interest if you borrow money
this is a new one I've been looking for
something like that all my life that's a
pretty good one but certainly if other
countries are going to be paid for
putting out money
I mean think of it they're borrowing
money instead of paying interest in
getting paid it's the craziest thing but
you know what other countries are doing
it look at Germany look at Japan look at
others and with the most Prime in the
world right now and we have this we have
the currency and we have we have the
power of the dollar so I know that the
Chairman is and he's done a very good
job over the last couple of months I
have to tell you that because I've been
critical but in many ways they call him
my MIP do you know that MIP is most
improved player it's called the most
improved player war did you ever get one
of them when you were playing baseball
Cory good baseball a lot the Chairman
he's my MIP right now for the last few
months I think he said a very good job I
disagree with him on one thing now and
that's negative rates and only because
we're paying zero good news with this
money you're talking about of the
stimulus we're paying zero we're down to
zero interest that's good but some
company countries and some states rather
and some also countries you look at but
we are we are paying right now zero and
other countries are paying less than
that if you can believe it they're
receiving money and I think we should be
in the exact same situations and by the
way states are getting tremendous deals
and borrowing so a lot of the states
that are coming to the federal
government they could go out and they
can borrow and they're getting
phenomenal rates some of our state's is
what I'm talking about
they're getting phenomenal borrowing
rates but you agree the stimulus
there's been some Republicans who
suggest that I don't know it's certainly
not the package that I saw today
basically if you look at that package
what they want more than anything else
is it's a voting package they want to be
able to make sure that Republicans can't
win an election by putting it all sorts
of mailing ballots now I don't know if
you do cuz the press doesn't report this
too much but we had two very big
victories last night we won very big Tom
Tiffany one very big in the great state
of Wisconsin you saw that that was last
night it came in that was a big one you
saw that done and won by a very very
substantial margin and in California of
all places we had a fantastic race and
this was all mail-in ballots this was
all mailed ballots and when they saw
because it was bad they said they were
losing three days ago and they end up
putting polling booths in into basically
Democrat areas but despite that it's
looking like Mike Garcia I don't know if
they've called the race yet but it was
substantially ahead that's the problem
with mail-in ballots are they going to
dump a whole pile of ballots on your
desk just before the election so the
problem with the mail-in ballots is
subject to tremendous corruption
tremendous corruption cheating and so
I'm against it and if you look at the
bill that Nancy Pelosi is putting in has
a lot to do with elections and then
we're not going to we're not going to
lose elections because of that and I do
think you should mention the fact that
the Republicans won two major
congressional seats last night I think
it's really worthy of mentioning that
the judge presiding over the Mike Flynn
case
as they say do a right do a dinner
arrival of course Nancy Pelosi knows it
you know obviously Thank You president
feebly but the judge presiding over the
Michael Flynn case
Emmett Sullivan ought to recuse himself
or be disqualified for being biased
against mr. Flynn I was just with
general Milley and some other generals
and I asked him about general Flynn do
you know him they said yes sir I've
known him for 20 years what do you think
he's an incredible man an incredible
soldier he's an incredible general this
is general Milley head of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff four-star he's done
fantastically he thinks general Flynn is
a great great gentleman and a real
fighter and when I see what is happening
to him
it's disgraceful and it was all the
rulers there by the way the FBI said he
didn't lie the FBI said he did not lie
so with all this stuff I'm hearing about
lying the FBI said he didn't like but
the sleazebag said well we don't care
what he's what they say we're saying he
like okay but the FBI you remember when
they left they said he didn't lie what
they've done to that man and that family
is a disgrace but I just tell you that
because they just left general Milley
and he said a great man and a great
soldier mister I won't talk about that
but he's going to be ok
and we're gonna be just fine kind of
very very saddened by what's happening
to general Flynn and others I want to
tell you right now and others
they do share who's concerned about
reopening what reopening the economy to
some stage lucky wants to play all sides
of the equation I think we're going to
have a tremendous fourth quarter I think
we're going to have a transitional third
quarter and I think we're going to have
a phenomenal next year I feel that we
are going to have a country that's ready
to absolutely have one of its best to
use Nick next year with all of the
stimulus and all of the fact that it's a
- pent-up demand like I haven't seen and
you see it right now these two really
professional good governors that do such
a you know work so hard I know both of
them very well what happens to be a
Democrat okay but we've worked together
and I think we've worked together very
well and one you would expect me to say
that but it happens to be true okay
really good job - but we've worked very
very well together they want to get
misstates open some governor's and some
perhaps partisans maybe for election
reasons don't want to have this they so
good and then some shouldn't open a
point yet you know they're not ready
they went through a lot and they're not
quite ready but know we're opening our
country people want to open the schools
are going to be open I was seeing the
other day Purdue is a great school great
College University and Purdue is opening
and others are opening and they're all
announcing it these are young people
these are students young students
they're a great shape they're in great
shape now when you have an incident to
one out of a million one out of five
hundred that will something happen
perhaps but you know you can be driving
to school and some bad things can happen
too so now we're going to open our
country
I'm surprised by this answer actually
because you know it's just to me it's
not an acceptable answer especially when
it comes to schools the only thing that
would be accepted was I said his
professors teachers etc over a certain
age I think they ought to take it easy
for another few weeks five weeks four
weeks who knows whatever it may be but I
think they have to be careful because
this is a disease that attacks age and
it attacks health and if you have a
heart problem if you have diabetes if
you're a certain age it's certainly much
more dangerous but with the young
children I mean and students it's really
just take a look at the statistics it's
pretty amazing businesses are concerned
about getting sued once they reopen it
will you be insistent on some sort of
shield from liability being in a phase
anything's done I would do that and
these are the new testing numbers so you
saw that but I was just showing this to
a group of people have said we're now
over ten million tests or we will be
very shortly like within a couple of
days look at that test this is us this
is the rest of the world okay we have
more tests and we have better tests yet
we have more tests that we have been
artists and we're going to have your
football team in your championship
football team right and we were the
Bison and tell us a little bit about the
team first of all you know they won the
championship and we were all set to have
them and what happened is the plague
came in and because of the plague came
in from China and because of the plague
we didn't have those great people who
will do a rain check okay but seriously
even if it's in a few months we'll do a
rain check
tell them about the team because it was
a tremendous season well let me say that
the team and Senator Hoeven was here as
in her Kramer
was here to hold Fidel but the first
lady was here she says hi but you hosted
him last year because they again won the
national championship this year January
and this is the 8th out of ninth year in
a row they've done that and they would
love to get back here with a rain check
so I watched the game on television the
championship game I didn't know too much
about it I don't think to watch too much
of the television football games right
and I'm saying yeah that he was really
good they were really good and then I
got a call from duck and I get a call
from John I get a call from our mother
very friendly senator right this is
wherever and they said do you think we
could possibly honor the team because we
honor the national champion and my
question was how would you team do
against the national champions they were
pretty good LSU this year they're not a
bad quarterback how do you think you
think ok make sure Adam well so then
we'll be able to answer your questions
pretty good radiology quarterback
started his career playing flag football
in elementary school in Fargo North
Dakota so that's well let the team know
we're going to do a rain check ok what
happened to the public companies that
don't return their PPP loans to the SBA
by tomorrow stuff well go after that
very seriously yeah if there's any
companies that got loans that they
weren't entitled to we'll go after them
very soon God big problems what's your
level of confidence that the Supreme
Court will ultimately rule in your favor
in the case involving your tax returns
I hope they will you have a situation
where a president has to be able to
focus on this and you know when you're
doing an audit who would give you know
the old days no president gave tax
returns a while ago I mean no president
gave tax returns but when you're under
audit who would want to give them it's a
very big thing but it would also take
time it would take and this people are
going to get ultimately people are going
to be getting returns they're going to
see that but I think you know I think it
went very well yesterday I thought it
was I have great respect for the Supreme
and I think the law has put out a very
strong case and from what I've read it
was a very strong case yeah please how
long do you and the vice president plan
to stay apart well it's an interesting
question I haven't seen Mike Pence and I
miss him but he was in the room with
somebody that tested positive and he did
not test positive he tested the opposite
he's in good shape but I guess we've
said for a little while we'll stay apart
because you don't know what happens with
this very crazy and horrible disease but
we speak a lot on the phone but I'm in
the White House Mike is at his office
but he's you know pretty much away from
people they did a great job he's done a
great job I think he'd say on the task
force he really has I think you've
pretty much gotten everything you wanted
and we try and get it to you quickly
yeah we talked to the vice president
regularly they've done we work very well
together with with Republican governors
and with Democrat governors and what are
you thinking of opening and explain what
you go to our we're most most suppose
businesses are open in Colorado pretty
much everything except for those social
businesses like bars and nightclubs a
few places have restaurants open we're
working on the rest soon but offices
manufacturing the salons pretty much all
people are back at in a safer way right
it's not the same way it was like if you
go I got my hair cut the other day it
looks good thank you you should have
seen it before I like I was it was crazy
what little is left of it so you know
they wore masks
I wore a mask so we're doing it in a
safe way all the stores are back in
April 27th we were one of the states
where we wanted to do that in a safe way
people are being responsible I mean you
know and it's that individual
responsibility that's going to make sure
that we can stay on this trajectory and
and hopefully hopefully restaurants in
May by the end
I mean they're already open in a few
places in our talk about because I go
there as you know and the ski slopes are
fantastic I there are those that say the
greatest anywhere how are you doing with
the skiing and you know it's a big
business for you you know it's a big
business it's also one of the reasons
that we got a lot of the virus in our
state because people come from all over
the world and all over the birthday and
so that's what led to the spread and so
most of the ski season is ending but
we're actually hopeful we have a lot of
people don't know that's been Colorado
we have a few areas that they're skiing
through July 4th and and we're hoping
that people will be able to ski again
David knows the secretary Barnard knows
this in a wrap abase and Wilf Creek
maybe Breckenridge Loveland in June
we're hoping the people can actually see
there's a lot of summer business and
springtime business and what are you
doing with it
you know it's we're really respecting
the the communities in our state because
they have allotted sake nobody is more
at stake than if in fact Jill Ryan who's
with us from Eagle she's our secretary
of health in Colorado she was a
commissioner in Echo County which is
worthless so they have the most at stake
for X stake economically and from health
perspective so you know we're really
respecting what the different
communities decide I think I think
there'll be some folks that are coming
back spending money in stores there'll
be other communities that say you know
what we have to wait a little bit longer
and it's been very traumatic for many of
those communities because Eagle County
for a while had the highest infection
rate in the country earlier yeah early
on and now there's people tell me
because everywhere goes everyone's
coming in yeah how has that been how is
the level of infection right now Eagle
County's done an amazing job as summit
county Pitkin County Hospital you know
all those areas they've gotten it under
control because they they acted early
they have great County Health
Department's they look at the science
and look at the data the residents
stayed home and in fact Eagle County was
one of the first in our state along with
Mesa County which secretary Barnardo's
well Grand Junction area to be able to
open up a little bit ahead of some of
the other areas in a safer way right in
a safer way yeah so like in Grand
Junction the restaurants are 25%
capacity so there's space we're looking
at ways that people can dine outdoors
sidewalks and and even on a lane of the
road because it's safer to be in that
environment
so those are the kinds of things that we
think about as we're just trying to get
back to as much normalcy as we can and
core are you working together very much
I know the governor and everybody else
do we speak regularly the governor said
a good job and I appreciate that and
here to help as much as we can
one of the things we did that Cori
introduced us to and worked on was
importing some tests from South Korea so
we have over there already being used in
our state we're also partnering with the
vice president in you on some thermo
Fisher tests that we think are coming in
very soon we're gonna I think 95 dollars
over here and go getting them very good
we're excited because we're running
through those tests from South from
South Korea but that's what's so
important is it supplies right it's the
we have the ability to do it the labs to
do it you guys sent around the labs we
have the capacity but it's getting the
tests in and so you know both with the
thermo Fisher test the Abbott tests the
souljah tests we're mixing and matching
across we have 32 free community testing
sites across our state some of them you
drive in some of them you walk in but
those are free and that's an addition to
the hospitals and doctors offices of
course you get tested there we have 30
teeth to free community testing sites
and you have to healthcare for that
state mr. president so I think the
governor talks about you have counties
that have a plant they're able to open
up the earlier than others because of
the work they're doing is so when when
the governor is talking about Grand
Junction you have restaurants that not
just open but you have dine in in some
of these restaurants which i think is
maybe some of the first around the
country to actually reopen to dine in
because of the good work that they have
done together and then we wanted to you
know for our restaurants were open
throughout this whole period in our
state right they just did delivery they
did take out did a curbside and we even
waive some of the laws so they could
sell alcohol curbside and sell alcohol
delivery because that extra piece can
make the difference between them staying
in business
those restaurants do with the together
uh you know you'll talk here from some
that are doing okay with it it doesn't
work for every restaurant and that's why
you know they need to be open for the
restaurant dining but for many of them
it's paid their bills and they've gotten
through it and it's held them not every
restaurant but I hear those stories
that's helped them get through it that
we've been able to make sure they've
been able to stay in business that's a
great test that's a new and a great test
[Music]
well first I want to just leave with
gratitude and say thank you to you for
your leadership and the vice president
and dr. Burks and the whole team it's
been a great partnership federal to
state to local in North Dakota and
secondly if you wanted to say the thanks
to all the great people in North Dakota
because like Jared in Colorado I mean we
relied a lot on individual
responsibility light touch from
government and had great birthday great
results and here we said today were
number two in the nation we passed New
York this week in terms of testing per
capita right so we've really driven in
we've tested over six percent using
different tests all different and you're
in good shape with the testing what
tests are you using well this has all
been the PCR the nucleic acid testing
and it's been across a number different
platforms thermal fisher abbott panther
and so we've got a variety of different
platforms but most of it driven through
our state lab which is at an order of
magnitude increase so we've got another
three shifts today and each shift is
doing more than three times they did
before so 10x increase going on there on
the testing side and then we're the
fifth lowest positive tivity rate in the
country so we've been you know alaska
and why you're ahead of us but we've
been right at the bottom in terms of
that you take those two things so why do
you join what do you tribute that well I
would say we very early on being a good
governor well you know geography helps
and the people that stayed helped those
two things but I'd say we took early
action to try to reduce
transmissible moments so we kept 93% of
the jobs in the state open but the 7% we
closed within bars restaurants and
personal care businesses everybody else
kept going all the construction all of
energy all of Ag including all of
elective surgery and hospitals kept that
going and because we never ran me we
were well-stocked we had a great medical
cache maybe we never took more than 2%
of our capacity and healthcare we have a
lot of great health care providers in
North Dakota only 2% we're going to Cove
it that's so we we were we were able to
then drive through that I mean we
handled the virus and really focus from
again Michelle comer here who leads our
Commerce Department we had have less to
worry about opening up because we never
really closed down but on that other 7%
we got bars restaurants personal care
businesses open on May 1st and all
that's going very well under new
operating procedures that everybody's
using the state to stay safe and then
what prices are going up a little bit
now so that you're 26 27 dollars a
barrel and pretty soon you'll be able to
the number that you have to be up to
it's no big difference well absolutely
because I mean what we do in North
Dakota is we power the world we feed the
world number two oil producer producing
state in the nation and in a lot of the
unemployment that we saw early on wasn't
related to the virus is related to the
demand destruction associated with the
oil price time great job John what do
you have to say about the state and the
job the governor and everybody else is
done listening I know it well yeah
listening to these two governors I was
governor for a long time tell us what
your approach is the right approach
you're working with the governors across
this country and empowering them to open
up as soon as they can safely based on
the conditions in their state and every
state is different and that's why that
approach is so important and then you
providing all that support along with us
in Congress with the cares Act you know
as well but you see that now with North
Dakota
Colorado and across the country so
that's why it's so important that you're
doing it the way that you're doing it
with these grief governors and we have
across the state so yeah thank you for
that and the other thing I want to
mention is for our farmers you know I
work a lot on yes but for our farmers
and ranchers you've been there for them
and hang in there with them they're
doing a whale of a job and they're so
important in our energy industry too and
we're sending them billions of dollars
of money that we took in from a country
that targeted them last year we gave
them 16 billion the year before we gave
them 12 billion and no other president
would have done that I can tell you it's
really important and appreciate and we
need to hang in there with him and the
only other thing I gotta tell you we
have a great governor as you know but he
is so data-driven that I was teasing dr.
Burks who's more data-driven these two
are teammates they're amazing together
yes it's they're just amazing that's
great Michelle do you have anything
visit wisdom that you know we've talked
a lot about lowering the curve but
I feel like we raised at the bottom and
we've had the good fortune to work very
very closely with our business community
and it's through that process and that
we can dialogue in the collaboration of
the hyper connectedness in our state
that we were able to build our what we
call North Dakota smart restart
protocols with our business community
over the span of about eight days and so
we were closed for 40 days and 40 nights
and we are opening in a Safeway event is
really thank you very much just to
finish off go ahead Thank You mr.
president
I want to thank the federal government
for its partnership on our coded 19
response and particularly the supplies
you've given us the tests and look
forward to that continuing and you know
the more people we can test and then we
can force multiply that with contact
tracing so we can quarantine people that
haven't even had a test yet that's
really you know the way that we're going
to contain the virus in Colorado we've
got a local public health department
that covers every county and they are
ready to do testing and contact tracing
and so that's our plan it's going to be
a statewide effort well thank you very
much terrific job - and well we're here
and when L see secretary Bernhard doing
a fantastic job because we have chance
to interact with him on national parks
we got great things going on in theater
Roosevelt National Park as we move ahead
with the Theodore Roosevelt Presidential
Library
we've got the US Fish and Wildlife BLM
and we've been great partners working
with the five tribal nations that are
headquartered in North Dakota with whom
we share geography and we've done great
collaboration with those tribal leaders
on testing to kovat but I just want to
thank a lot of difficulty in the
different tribes
come another thank the Secretary's envy
I am for all their support as well
through all this David you've done a
great job how do you feel comfortable
with all those cameras right behind you
so uh you know you you gave me clear
direction to work with governor's to
open things up we work with local
communities our parks my goal is that
we're right right on the shoulder of the
governor we've worked with Larimer
County and Health Department and asked
his part to bring that online we've
opened up Theodore Roosevelt and we're
on we just announced today the timing of
the opening for Yellowstone so when you
get into this parks open right
absolutely
I hope everybody's listening the parks
are opening there and rapidly actually
with those governor's right and with
those governors you want the help from
the game and even with the counties
absolutely within the state and you know
we're all excited because recreative and
healthy the flipside is we're not yet
ready to have all the people from other
states and other countries well we need
what has local communities to bring so
in all cases you're working with
governors and open and local town
absolutely that's great job thank you
good neighbor thank you very much go
travel on America's Airlines right have
a great conference and their great
confidence in us and they have great
confidence in the airlines we've saved
the airlines with twenty five billion
dollars in another twenty five billion
dollars and we have airlines that are
now in good shape I mean they obviously
they're going to pick up with the fares
and with the seats but the airline
industry is in good shape we've been
able to save the airline in this room
which is would have been devastating if
that happened so they're a good shape
thank you very much